welcome everyone taking time out from
you could be starting your holidays
earlier anyways today is the symposium
presentation of Meena Mishra who you all
know whose PhD student pre-doctoral and
alum fellow and she's going to do her
symposium presentation which is an
overview of research that feeds into one
starting to do their dissertation so
just a little bit of background Meena
previously worked here at OHSU in a
clinical research role managing and
coordinating clinical trials at oncology
and bone marrow transplant in the
division of pediatric hematology and
oncology in Doron Becker's she has a
master's in biotechnology from Banaras
Hindu University I pronounced that right
and then also has an mph degree from
University of South Carolina before she
moved to the northwest and so her
research interests are in secondary uses
of electronic health record data and
she's going to give us an overview of
some of the areas that she's interested
in for her dissertation work thank you
everyone for coming to my symposium
today in spite of it being the start of
the holiday season so I've been
exploring the use of intimate
informatics tool to implement system
level policy more specifically I've been
kind of researching how clinical
practice guidelines have been applied at
a system level can take care of our give
clinicians health clinicians make
decisions
so as I was researching this I was
reminded about this saying from
Shakespeare my famous play Merchant of
Venice if to do were as easy to know
what we're good to do chapels would be
churches and Poorman cottages Prince's
spell princes palaces and so as it is
it's quite hard to make the transition
when from you know knowing what what is
good to do to do actually get to doing
it but what if we don't know actually
there is no clear light or path and we
don't know what's the right way to go
about doing things and that's where
clinical practice guidelines comes in
basically it's a way of packaging
evidence in the form of recommendations
that decision maker can use to make
decision to take care of patients so
this is the roadmap that I would be
following today I'll give you a little
bit of background about prescription
opioids the significance of this topic
why are we looking at it what you know
why are we looking at clinical practice
guidelines help make clinicians make
better decisions to take care of adults
with chronic pain I'll then give you a
systems view of the opioid prescription
and discuss role of CPG in that I'd anif
I some gaps from the literature that I
came across and kind of highlight a
problem that is worth researching and
proposed some research questions so what
are prescription opioids we keep hearing
daily in the news they are basically a
class of drugs which have morphine like
effects they they attach to receptors in
the brain and spinal cord and other
receptors in your body and interfere
with pain messages as a result patient
feels less pain there are three
different categories of opioids
natural-based codeine morphine there are
natural opioids some ice
or man man-made basically they are made
in the lab with natural product and
natural chemicals and then they are
synthetic like fentanyl which are purely
synthesized by chemicals that are not
naturally found so these prescription
opioids actually are controlled
substances they are regulated by Drug
Enforcement Administration and DEA in
short and they are actually categorised
from level 5 to level 1 in order of
increasing potential for causing harm or
causing risk for abuse and decreasing
potential for medical qualities and as
you can see prescription opioids
actually fall in schedule 2 and so they
have very high potential for abuse and
dependence and though they do have some
medicinal qualities and as a result can
be obtained by prescription some
definitions about that you will come
across in the presentation when I'm
talking about adults I mean ages 18 and
over chronic pain is a pain that lasts
for three or more months past the time
of normal tissue healing Co T in short
khat is chronic opioid therapy that
lasts for more than three months
PDMP is a prescription drug monitoring
program this is a state-run monitoring
program an electronic database that
collects information when whenever our
control substance is filled at the
pharmacy
then you'll come across dsm-5 which is
nothing but diagnostic and statistical
manual of mental disorder and currently
it's in the fifth edition o UD is opioid
use disorder and math is medication
assisted treatment this is basically a
treatment that is provided to people
with substance abuse disorder and
what happens in this treatment is opioid
antagonists are given to the to somebody
who is abusing oud these antagonists
actually bind to the same receptors as
the opioids and they help wean the
person from opioid use disorder because
they these substances do not produce the
same kind of response and they have a
ceiling effect so they don't provide the
same kind of high aura phoria that
usually an opioids produce so to
highlight some data from national drug
from the CDC as we can see that death
from accidental overdose of opioid has
gone up from 1999 to 2017 it has gone up
almost four times it was right
death from accidental overdose of
opioids ranked fifth in 2017 the odds of
drying dying from the from a single
overdose and it's actually ranked over
the odds of dying from motor vehicle
accident and if we consider just the
prescription opioids not the total
opioids prescription opioids constitutes
about 35% of the death of the total from
the total opioid death so clearly there
is the role that opioid prescription
opioid is playing in the opioid crisis
or opioid epidemic not only does it
cause death as a result of overdose it
also prescription opioids also is a
gateway for other kinds of addiction
like heroin this is the data from NIH
where is the estimated that 46 percent
who misuse prescription opioids
transition to heroin and about 80
percent of the people
use heroin first misuse prescription
opioids so these are alarming figures
and and the reason for this is basically
heroin is more is cheaper and easy to
access on the streets so here are some
facts about prescription opioid
problematic use of opioid is common
among chronic pain patients treated with
prescription opioids there is
good-quality evidence that opioid
therapy for chronic pain is associated
with an increase in the risk for opioid
abuse and opioid overdose there is
insufficient evidence regarding the
efficacy of opioid for long term chronic
pain and oh you D increases the risk for
oh you D increases as a function of dose
at any given level of exposure so we
cannot say that this is a safe dose you
know we can start somebody at this and
they'll be fine and no matter what does
you start somebody out you know as you
increase the dose or lengthen the time
period of that dose there's a risk for
you d so why do we still prescribe
opioids we do so because considerable
percentage of the u.s. population
actually a deal with chronic pain almost
forty percent of the population and
there is sixty fourteen percent of this
actually have severe and disabling pain
and as a result opioid continue to be a
viable option freedom to oxy option for
this population till we find better cure
which we are working on so here's a
systems view of prescription opioids
basically when a patient walks in with a
pain to a provider the provider has a
option to put them on non opioid pain
medication or they can choose opioid the
patient then fills the prescription at
the pharmacy and the data is collected
by PDMP the patient either takes and
gets better there is all there's a the
pain results or they continue to
experience pain
as a result they come back for Maury
Falls and there's another decision point
where clinician can make a decision to
either continue with this opioid
treatment or suggest some alternate way
of dealing with the pain if the patient
stays on this pain meds
long enough I mean as early as seven
days to you know even as long as a year
within that period they might the
patient may develop opioid dependence
the opioid dependence can lead to opioid
use disorder or UD in short which can be
done you know diagnosed using the dsm-5
manual there are lists of eleven
criteria in that manual and if you meet
two of those criteria it's enough to
diagnose somebody with four UD the
symptoms of UD can go from mild to
severe depending on how many symptoms
the patient needs and this disorder
leads to opioid seeking behavior as a
result of which the patient displays
some risk behaviors like diversion
illegally obtaining the opioids or even
getting getting addicted to heroin and
these risk behaviors can lead to opioid
overdose so this is in brief
you know the system's way of looking at
what happens when when somebody is put
on opioid long term or at high dose so
here are all the criteria that is listed
in dsm-5 Manimal basically there's
failure to fulfill responsibilities is
used and physically has use of opioids
and physically hazardous situation
there's a craving and uncontrolled
craving for opioids there's a lack of
social or interpersonal you know for
there's a problem related to social and
interpersonal issues there is a use of
larger amount of or longer than intended
there's difficulty tapering opioids when
recommended to taper there is an
increase in time spent to
to get opioid use it and and recover
from any paper physical nation tries to
do they also there is a there the
patient tends to give up on important
aspects of their life there's ongoing
use despair mmm despite of the problems
and then there are some symptoms that in
indicative of tolerance and withdrawal
so as a result of these issues we have
clinical practice guidelines I already
discuss what they are and CDC the most
recent clinical practice guidelines are
from 2016 which was also updated I
believe around 2018 which is basically a
recommendation list of recommendation
for risk reduction they essentially face
focusing on reducing harm these
recommendations come from systematic
review of evidence from observational
studies and from expert consensus and
I've already gone over it and briefed
the evidence that came out with the
systematic reviews the benefit of
long-term use of opioid is lacking
evidence is not supported by evidence
and short-term benefits of opioids
actually there is some in terms of
improving pain but not improving
function there is insufficient evidence
that long-term use of for using opioids
long term for certain indications like
back pain headache and fibromyalgia so
the political guidelines actually have a
list of checklist that the physicians
can look at when they are initiating or
continuing opioids for chronic pain they
have recommendations for opioid
selection dosage duration follow-up and
discontinuation but the thing that I
will be focusing on mainly is assessing
the risk and addressing the harm of
opioid use this
there is a list of checklist on
recommendations where physicians are
asked or recommended to look for risk
factors in the EHR to review PDMP data
to use during drug testing and to look
for a cool prescribing of
benzodiazepines they are lists of the
kind of drugs that are given for anxiety
and they also call risk they also cause
respiratory depression like opioids do
and also there's a recommendation to
identify oud and to arrange for
treatment of AUD so this is where I
probably I will be focusing mostly for
physicians and their recommendation for
physician physicians to look for known
risk factors and what are some of the
known risk factors they're like eat
illegal drug use prescription drug use
for non-medical reason history of
substance substance use disorder or
overdose mental health health conditions
like depression or anxiety sleep
disordered breathing and concurrent
benzodiazepine again I've you know other
things to look for is your in drug
testing and PDMP so these guidelines
actually are available to physicians in
the form of clinical reminders in EHR
there are dashboards or registries that
can be that the physician can use to
monitor their patients who are taking
opioids there are some advisory texts in
order and in the order sets that reminds
provider to evaluate the benefits and
harm and there's also the CDC
prescribing checklist is available from
within EHR for providers to pull up and
take a look at while they are
considering opioid therapy there is also
implementation of PDMP data from within
a gear chart so there is a way to
integrate the data in
the physicians workflow so they can
review the PDMP data there are
documentation templates that are
available to the physician so that they
can attest to reviewing the PDMP and
record any issues or findings from from
the PDMP data so this these gaps came up
while i was reviewing literature and
trying to understand how physicians are
using the tools that are being provided
to them I basically came across that
there was variability in the
interpretation of opioid risk there is
under utilization of you UDS urine drug
screen and opioid use agreements these
are agreements between physicians and
the patient when they initiate opioid as
to you know the dose or the frequency of
visit that the patients have to keep in
order to continue on opioids so they
under utilisation of oh you a as well
and also PDMP data they are concerned
and reluctance among the younger
providers to manage and prescribe
opioids for their patients with chronic
pain lack of time training and access to
resources are perceived as significant
barriers for taking care of patients in
a busy primary care setting educating
providers in opioid risk assessment did
not change the rate of risk assessment
in actual practice even though there was
an increase in the knowledge and
attitude to do so so here is a table
from well this study that I came across
where this is a result of a survey that
was sent to the physicians and medical
students as well and asking them what
are some of the information that they
look for when they are prescribing
opioids and the physician said that
looking at the information that they
most often used when prescribing opioids
was looking at patients pain history and
pain description while they they could
have used if
if the information was easily available
they could have used information like
previous treatment experiences and
average pain rating over the past week
for making the decision so what uh what
are other things that that are available
in the clinical practice guideline and
that physicians could use to assess
benefit and harm the CDC also recommends
that the use of some psychometric tools
like ort and soap to assess or whether a
patient is misusing opioids or but
whether there is whether there is a
danger for them to use miss use opioids
however the you the the use of these
tools there's a low quality evidence
that is actually does any good there is
also the lack of evidence in the EHR
that EHR a a documentation is good
enough for for patient for providers to
make decision this variation in the
documentation practices and if and if
different terminologies are used to
inconsistently to document a problem of
opioid use so there is there was this
study where they found that the
prevalence of opioid misuse or abuse
varies very widely from 0 percent to 50
percent I don't know where they got to
your person but it's making and it's
making it challenging for a clinician or
inform of policy decisions or to
implement and measure interventions
so I would go over this this thing
verbatim as it says and so beer with me
as I read read it out along to you it's
also there for you to read with me but
this is an anecdotal comment from dr.
mary picard she's a provider here that
prescribes opioids for her patients and
this is what she says OAD chart
footprint is hard the reason it is hard
is that it is such a sensitive topic for
patients and many have hard time except
accepting the diagnosis so until it is
severe it is common for doctors to go
light on the charting footprint
sometimes it is left off the problem
list sometimes it is charted in an op q
sway like features concerning for or not
named at all it can really break trust
between patients and provider if this is
added to the problem list or used as a
visiting nurses
it is commonly left out of diagnosis
code even when it's the main concern for
the visit there are some tools in the
chart including ort and I already talked
about the the you know the evidence
supporting the use of this tool there
are some tools in the chart including
the ort flow sheet to screen for use
disorder and dsm-5 flow sheet to screen
for use disorder but I do not believe we
have an effective way to discern who and
how many patients truly have use
disorder by scouring charts
electronically or even by doing a manual
review of chart moving along she says
that in our opioid review board for our
clinic we goal at Lance when we search a
chart that we are reviewing to try to
find hints of or ud in early stages for
example I personally run a list of
search term one at a time through the
chart search function to see if they
have seen people who comprehensively
chart pain to see if they have signs of
adverse effects or overuse so and she
also lists some of the search words that
she use to review the chart
so that's a problem a a clinician a busy
clinician using search words to go one
at a time and look through the chart to
diagnose somebody with oh you D is a
huge issue and what do we make of the
data in PDMP there are limitations in
terms of accuracy accessibility and
interpret ability of the data in PDMP as
well the objective criteria for example
for indicating risk behavior is if a
person is is filling more than four
opioid prescription or seeing from more
than 40 it's indicated according to
[Music]
what's been provided the recommendation
is that there is a danger for that or
there is some kind of risk behavior that
the patient has however many patients
have multiple prescribers because of
poor primary care access and because of
visits to the IDI for acute increase of
pain and there are conditions that
require them to come to go to multiple
specialists so so how do we interpret
PDMP data in this in these scenarios so
I went through the literature and found
that there is an insufficient evidence
that PDMP implementation is associated
with change in fatal overdose however
there are certain administrative
qualities and features that may help in
in in getting some benefit out of the
PDMP data and these and mystery feature
include mandatory provider review that
provider and you know absolutely for
every one he sees should go in the PDMP
data and review what it says or what he
sees there there's also you know the
providing PDMP authorization to all
providers who prescribe opioid is
something that should be considered also
there the advantage of push versus pull
where you know instead of every time
provider going and looking into the PDMP
data for signs of
risk behavior PDMP pushing this to the
provider is another way of benefiting
from the PDMP program edition in
addition a monitoring for non scheduled
drug which is also beneficial this is a
qualitative inquiry study about you
nisshin's use of PDMP program and again
I'm going to read and excuse me for that
but some participants of the program
which is the physicians they mainly
mainly from the pain clinics they report
checking the PDMP with every patient
every time others check only for new
patients and for new opioid prescription
offer patients for whom they suspect
abuse participants described varied
approaches to sharing the PDMP
information with patients including
openly discussing potential addiction or
safety concern avoiding discussion
altogether and approaching discussion
confrontationally participants describe
patient anger or denial as a common
response and noted the role of patient
satisfaction surveys as an influence of
prescribing
so this is this is huge like even when
they find something that indicates that
patient is abusing or having some kind
of risk behaviors how do they bring if
they bring it up with their patients and
you know one of the thing that that
providers are hesitant to bring it up
with the patient is the patient
satisfaction survey also there is no
study that evaluates effectiveness of
policy that cpg implementation
system-wide on the actual patients
opioid use behavior or misuse behavior
so putting it all together these are
some of the research areas that I've
been exploring there is a need to
understand barriers and facility
facilitators for risk assessment at
opioid initiation during opioid
maintenance and for chronic
non-malignant pain these need to
understand how physicians are reviewing
risk in the light of
adequate risk assessment tools like the
ort inadequate documentation in EHR and
inadequate systems like PDMP they we
need to understand the effectiveness
effectiveness of CPG integration in EHR
in patient actual outcomes which is the
misuse of opioids and we need to get
better at identifying patients with IUDs
so that we can direct them to Matt and
alternative therapies so these are some
of the sub questions under each question
areas
what are again what key actors determine
opioid risk assessment and management by
primary care providers we can look at
what are the information needs of the
physicians for risk assessment what
information systems and tools of the
physicians find useful than making
prescription opioid decisions and how do
physicians interpret information in
various information system like EHR PDMP
to make decisions about opioid
prescription this is an interesting
question like we all have come across
this that just providing the informatics
tool is not enough and that inference
informatics tool has to fit within the
workflow of the provider so we can look
at you know is the PDMP absence access
from within the patient EHR does it
improve PDMP utilization Dave there was
a time and as as recent as this year I
think with this year when every provider
I'm talking about Oh Hsu wide clinics
had to go outside of the EHR log into a
PDMP site with their separate login and
password and access information about
each patient but there has been
implementation of PDMP axes with from
within EHR and and so we can definitely
look at what role does
provision of Informatics tools inside
the in the provider workflow
what role does that play in the use of
that tool and this implementation of CDC
guidelines in general in EHR result in
better patient outcome or not
pshh at OHSU P the CDC guidelines were
implemented in the August of 2017 so
there is a period of time that we can
look at prior to and after that and see
if that has improved pain and increased
function if there's increased
identification of patient with IUD or if
there's increased referral to match
services for patients with IUD and of
course I mean this has been my favorite
can be improved the way the physicians
can diagnose or you d like can you
improve you know the time that appear
the pitch their provider spends looking
for the risk factors inside EHR and come
up with some automated way of I'm fine
IUD patients so some methods that I have
been thinking to address my research
questions are for the barriers and
facilitators definitely doing a some
kind of rapid qualitative inquiry using
immersion and crystallization and
purposive sampling we can look at a
grounded Theory approach and and if I
concepts and themes and develop a theory
this is a checklist actually of
that has been developed for
implementation for chronic diseases this
is a tailored implementation of chronic
diseases checklist basically what it is
is if they are 57 determinants of
practice change when you're trying to
change practice as how physicians should
practice medicine
they are 57 different determinants that
affect that change and these 57
different determinants have been listed
in seven main domains this include the
guideline factors which is nothing but
clinical practice guidelines individual
health professional factor patient
factors professional interaction how the
physician interacts with with the peer
incentives and resources capacity for
organizational change and social and
political and legal factors and all
these 57 different determinants fall
under these seven domains and they
affect the change in practice it's worth
looking at these factors but I'm trying
to determine develop my theory for
looking at barriers and facilitators for
risk assessment for opioid misuse so for
the second question that I had was how
do we quantify whether there is
integration of PDMP in in EHR increases
utilization or not we can there's a
unique opportunity as I said at Hsu
where the PDMP axis has been implemented
from within EHR and there are certain
clinics that are able to access from
outside the future then we can identify
PDMP if there are more PDMP queries or
or EHR documentation of PDMP data and
see if that makes a difference
and this is interesting this is a slide
from one of these survey results
basically it shows that 50% of the
physicians said that had it not been for
a separate login for PDMP from outside
of EHR they would have used the PDMP
data so there is a role that that access
to PDMP actually plays and in physicians
use of the PDMP data so can we look at
what role does clinical practice
guidelines implementation say what role
that plays in patient outcome yes of
course we can do interrupted time series
analysis and look at the patient peg
score which is nothing but pain
enjoyment and general activity score
that's collected and from before and
after the CPC implementation in the EHR
and see if there's a difference there so
this is as I said this is my favorite
like can we use NLP in machine learning
techniques to better identify patient
with IUD so here is an example of a
table from one of the study that were
used machine learning techniques - I am
diagnosed patient with lupus and they
essentially used the is different
learning algorithm eluding algorithms
using different data forms bag of words
and see you eyes and found that neural
network with using C wise had the best
result followed by random forest
so there is a role for machine learning
to untie and diagnose patients but and
you know we can definitely look at what
two vector inversion because that's a
more powerful technique when you have a
lot of data and it's a more powerful
technique in this scenario where I'm
trying to use oh you D it's it it offers
a way of defying not just binomial like
sorry by nominal classification of
whether somebody has a disease or not
has a disease but at multiple levels
like you know whether they are dependent
or they have misuse or abuse and so they
they can be different different
categories of outcomes that we can look
at using work to vector image
inversion it's a very powerful technique
that I'm excited about so it's not just
enough to provide tools to make it easy
for providers to you know look for
things what we should be striving for
actually is providing a decision support
tool at the point of care and here is
one such architecture where you know we
can look at the structured data and
unstructured data and aggregate it as
that a unified data platform creates
some kind of unified data platform and
provide logic that flows from a clear
process models and you know apply those
rules and deliver knowledge at the point
of care so this is something you know
like a probably my postdoc or maybe
later in years
definitely something that's worth doing
so how does my research how would that
help we will definitely be
to understand what factors are
deterministic for successful
implementation of the system-wide risk
assessment policy we can I defy the role
the technology integration in workflow
plays an opioid risk assessment we can
look at the effect of system-wide policy
on patient outcomes not just you know
yes we decrease the amount of opioids
were giving yes we decreased you know
you increased the naloxone prescription
for patient about certain dose limits we
are prescribing safer but are we
actually improving patient outcomes in
terms of improving their misuse of
opioids and definitely looking at NLP
and machine learning techniques to
better and if I owe you D would be a
huge help these are my references I
thank the animals and and training
fellowship for giving me this provider
opportunity to research the staff and
mentors our demise my symposium
committee dr. Karen Eden dr. Niccole
vice cough dr. Joni ash and dr. Karen
Cohan a huge time to dr. Mary Pinkett
for taking out time from her busy work
as you know as it is she's really busy
doing what she should be doing but she
takes the time out to provide me
information doctor Safina Qureshi dr.
Wayne Backlund and the de maiz students
and peers I'm really really good thank
you so much
[Applause]
i Mena thank you so much for your talk
so I was curious whether in your
discussions with clinicians or anything
else you've read or that you've come
across if anyone because I you brought
up that quote from a dr. Mary Pickett
about like the whole like naming of the
diagnosis being really at the core of
establishing trust with patients and how
that sort of you can how you how
actually writing that down in the EHR
can be sort of problematic in itself and
I was curious to know whether you came
across anything about like making time
spent on patient education for opioid
use disorder as some as a possible like
quantitative metric that is used in any
any sort of you know way of recording
hey this is a thing that's going on with
this patient but isn't actually a
diagnosis but is a sort of quantitative
measure of you know a potential health
issue
so specifically time spent on patient
education for opioid use disorder yeah
that's an interesting question so I have
not come across in my conversation
definitely definitely education is a big
piece of it all you know these
stigmatizing or UD disorder you know and
definitely is interesting path that one
can take that do we do we provide some
kind of education material to patients
when they come in with the oud you know
a potential for you oh you did disorder
or when we start them on opioids if you
provide them with education tools does
it help
more what I was getting at was the like
actual recording of the time spent doing
that education right because that in
itself like is sort of a marker of like
hey this is something that and you can
track that over time and use it
potentially that's something worth
looking at I'm not sure if they document
the time spent educating or there are
now how much time are they required to
spend educating the busy but I think I
had a kind of a different question
related to the patience you had talked
early on about the patient satisfaction
surveys in the relationship with the
clinician and I was curious whether any
of the literature you saw or any of the
things you've thought about in terms of
the chart review are also looking at
what is said in the patient portal for
the patients and how do you how does it
show up there you know if at all because
I think about some of these systems that
can write things to your version of the
chart how transparent could you be or
want to be about also writing some of
that to the patient portal you know like
especially if you're always checking the
PDMP you know like how much is that okay
to let the patient know this is just
part of my practice and I'm doing this
and by the way you can see here's the
data about you or not see the data about
you from the PDMP so I did come across
some from doing some review that in
certain situations
I guess physicians do you carry on some
kind of communication with the patient
directly about what they're seeing in
PDMP again it depends on you know what
how they perceive the patient is going
to react the patient barriers so as far
as that data being available in patient
portal I don't know very much
about it but I mean PDMP data can be
used as a platform for discussion
between patient and provider to you know
deliver better care
interesting talk thanks for sharing I
was curious whether you had already or
had any plans to sort of shadow some of
those clinical interactions I think you
heard from people that they're you know
they're highly complex and a lot of
these issues you know they're they're
they're not necessarily about they're
clearly not about technology and some of
those con really complicated
relationship dynamics no matter what
sort of system of classification we use
just sort of try to instantiate those
they they really will never be able to
be fully captured so I just feel like
for you it might be highly valuable to
get a chance to see that if you haven't
already yes I have tried and so far I've
been so busy with my coursework I have
tried to reach out to providers I would
be more than happy to shadow clinicians
to gain better understanding of of this
problem and see you know how we can
develop the tools in the light of what
we see definitely I'll approach I will
be approaching more providers to see if
I can shadow few things talk thanks for
this and I want to piggyback off of that
as you're you're playing through rapid
qualitative inquiry having an
observational component so understanding
you could ask a provider what do you
think you need but then the last
question what do you see or you perceive
from that interaction as potential
barriers even though they had every
intention to use the system so if you
thought about potential third factors
that could confound whether this
actually gets recorded
I'm was struck by your your your graphs
are really graphic no that's fine you're
early graph that showed two thousand two
two thousand two thousand thirteen to
fourteen there's a change in trajectory
of the opioid related deaths and you
would think at that time there was an
increase in use of technology and using
these these decisions support aids yet
the deaths go up so there's potentially
a third factor in there that might
confound your results yeah that's a
thanks for bringing that up so the
increase in in the trajectory that you
were seeing was because of increased
prescription of opioids to patients with
there was a you know long back opioids
were not the first line of treatment
that somebody gave to patient with pain
however there was a change in
perspective or the practice when pain
was considered as a fifth vital sign
somewhere in the early 2000 late 1990s
and that kind of escalated the use of
opioids for pain as a result you know
that the push that you saw that
increased was from that practice that
practice change that happened as a
result of accepting a pain as a fifth
vital sign that happened in the early
2000s but that 2013 to 14 in question
point you had increased prescriptions
that whole time but what happened in
2013 and 14 maybe it was actually the
physicians having these systems and I
mean I think I think your point is
well-taken although you know there we
need to be careful about correlations
but one could potentially correlate the
increased use of electronic health
records the high tech act meaningful use
but they probably don't have a lot to do
with it III mean you know actually one
of the one of the few advantages to
being older is that you know you've seen
these ships you know in the early 90s
there was a big concern about overuse of
opioids and then it probably went too
far and it swung back to that early
2000s where at pain as the fifth vital
sign and now it's swinging back so yeah
the question is what's what's the cause
in the effect
thank you um my guess as a actual like
chemical dependency counselor would be
that it was the introduction of narcan
that accounted for a lot of the decrease
in in deaths because they became more
widely available and particularly for
first responders to just all I had to do
is inject it into somebody and you could
kind of nearly literally bring them back
to life um but I think that Chris's
point is a good one that I guess the
fundamental thing for me is like well
what did bring about actual change and
what out what patient outcomes do you
use to measure that because it seems
like from your review like PDMPs the use
of them didn't really change things very
much although that could be because it
was kind of difficult to access them and
how do you measure it in like a decrease
in the number of deaths and if so how do
we connect that information to that
information because it's not necessarily
in the EHR do we do we look at that in
terms of maybe the person doesn't show
up and again and then we know okay they
stopped using or they at least they
stopped using prescription only put
opioids anyway I just wonder what your
thoughts were about what brings about
actual change in people's use behavior
and what outcomes are would be best to
actually measure that well that's a
that's a huge question like there are so
many theories that have been developed
to you know to help us understand what
brings about change in behavior of
anyone so in the light of like what
should we be even looking at like are we
changing actual patient behavior or
patient outcomes or not it's a very
complex
complex topic and very hard to measure
you know I mean how do we you know look
at what kind of data do we look at to
even say if the patient had is there's
change in the patient's misuse of
opioids like you know what if again as
you said they might not be going to
another provider they may be using
heroin on the street and they does not
being captured in EHR anymore and we are
thinking maybe they're not using anymore
but you know we don't know so given that
fact and also kind of the majority of
the questions that people have been
asking I wonder if I really the best
outcome might be to look at the trust
between the provider and the patient
right because it seem like people are
kind of based on these questions
interested in that topic and it's true
but that's important I think that's the
number one definitely we can measure the
trust I don't know I mean they could be
yeah way to measure that is to measure
trash that's another research question
out there and yeah look looking at you
know again looking at patient
satisfaction with their quality of care
is probably not a good good measure
so yeah that's something interesting to
explore thanks for bringing it up
just going off that question I know that
you said you were planning on looking at
pain scores were there other instruments
that you are looking planning and
looking at uh remember so ya mean score
our PEG scores are one of them but since
the clinical practice guidelines do
recommend looking at a utilisation of
Yuling drug tests if there's a change in
rate of that but in terms of like the
the patient facing thing one option in
terms of outcomes would be if there are
certain quality of life instruments that
are used frequently in the clinical
setting which would be something that
has a clinician about but I know there
are certain promise tools and things
like that so if any of those are
frequently integrated into the care
process would be another option that's a
good yeah good suggestion the PEG score
does look at some aspect of it like they
do have scored for an enjoyment so they
kind of reflect whether the patient has
improved in terms of quality of like
life but not in a very detailed way but
definitely we can look at tools
you came back to slide 26
it's like 36 sorry we should have gone
the other way around right now that had
started
[Music]
you want to use the natural language
process to protect the patient at risk
for UD or determined by patients but the
OD was diagnosis by dsm-5 right yeah so
as I said that the OED can be diagnosed
using at a minimum two of the eleven
criteria that is listed in the dsm-5 not
sure there are any problem for the I
mean DSM
so we do I mean providers do have a flow
sheet in which they can record you know
decent five criteria but as I said they
are hesitant to do so they don't want to
unless there is an extreme cause for
concern
because they don't want to break the
trust between them and patient so either
there is that with that aspect of it
that prevents a fish provided from
explicitly documenting but they do an
aside Mary Mary Pickett said that
instead of calling it an IUD or
documenting in a flow sheet she does put
some symptoms in the chart for her you
know for people who are doing review of
these patients
so there are breadcrumbs that we can
follow but not an explicit for you D
terminology that's used so you want to
use language process clinical notes yes
and help to define the patient that they
should be I mean the problem of the
patient they should be now that's a good
questions may be something that I can
look and write a paper about and
thinking along those lines of clinical
entities that have things they have a
lot of stigma and they require a whole
lot of strong qi to really improve
results on I'm thinking like obesity
would be a really common one that has a
pretty good bit of stigma we don't we
were told all the time you know that you
can push things but it's pretty hard to
get that moving sometimes
and but then also sort of the whole
field of psychiatry and in psychology so
I wonder if maybe there's some some
literature on a parallel topic tried to
use NLP to detect things for some you
know high stigma psychiatric diagnosis
or something and then I have one other
idea was is that Oregon I believe last
year was the first year that they've
required all licensed providers by the
Oregon Medical Board to complete a video
training on substance I think it's like
the nature of pain and alternative
treatments and things like that and I
and and I wonder if maybe there are some
ways to look at before and after or if
there was a group of folks that got it
earlier on yeah I mean there's a lot of
Education going on and the provider
sphere to educate them about
last question I have to do is just from
your perspective it seems like you could
focus on the conversation with the
patient and whether it's getting into
the note whether they're using the PDMP
whether they're prescribed it using
guidelines adherent care or whether
there's some outcome for the patient to
find it how you will which area
interests you the most or do you feel
that this is the one that's going to get
the most the most bang for your PhD but
it's very hard to say that I mean these
as we have all learned you know caring
for a patient is like it's it's within
the sphere of the socio technical aspect
we have to look at all aspects to
provide quality care my personal bias is
I like machine turning and the use of
technology to better under 5 patients
something that I would love to do and
provide information that the provider
need at the point of care not looking in
the into the different places to you
know combined the whole picture but
looking at the point of fear so
definitely something that I would love
to do but understanding you know in
order to develop that tool at the point
of care we need to understand you know
what's going on actually you know what
are what are the information needs that
we can you know bring together to prove
to make a tool and that in order to
understand that information needs
definitely you know we have to do some
qualitative study so doing the
qualitative piece and then doing you
know some kind of informatics tool is my
dream research project
my question I'm wondering if it might
not be useful for you to study someplace
besides OHSU or in addition to OHSU but
it occurs to me that well you're talking
about epic specific having this access
there might be other EHRs that have a
different kind of access there there
might already be some decision support
out there that would help with this but
I'm specifically thinking about
federally qualified health centers and
you know if there might be a different
level of trust and you know different
dynamics that go that's more
socio-technical so I hate to give you
more work but that would be my
suggestion